♪ (electronic music) ♪
We're introducing Android Jetpack,
our next generation
of components and tools
along with architecture guidance
designed to help you accelerate
your Android development.
You told us it was hard to do
backwards compatibility,
so we build the support library.
You told us it was hard to manage
your app as data changes,
so we built the architecture components.
And we heard you wanted more,
so we're building more.
(Sumiran Pradhan) Android
architecture components gives us
a template to write
production-ready Android code,
which helps us
on-board new developers faster.
Jetpack is made up
of components in four categories:
foundation, architecture,
behavior, and UI.
Each component is individually adoptable
and built to maintain
backwards compatibility.
(Andy Lawton) Android architecture
components are very modular.
So we're allowed to pick and choose
what feature sets we want
that are applicable to our app.
(Karen Ng) Lifecycle-aware observers
and observable components
allow for a separation of concerns
that create testable,
robust, high quality apps.
One of the most important things
that we don't have to worry about is
what code goes where.
So that helps us test a few models.
It helps us build robust code.
We do not have to be lifecycle-aware
and just helps new devs come in
and then write a proper
modulized production-ready code
without having to add
all of these extra different subjects.
It also takes advantage
of Kotlin language features
that make you more productive.
Jetpack manages tedious activities
like persistence, background tasks,
navigation, and life cycle management.
So you could eliminate boilerplate code
and focus on what makes your app great.
(Andy Lawton) Database persistence
has been a nightmare
for the Android community for years
and Room is a huge improvement.
And Room was thought out
with testability in mind
so we're able to add test covers
that we weren't able to before
on the persistence layer
without having to build
any infrastructure around that.
(Karen Ng) With Android Jetpack,
we're eliminating whole classes of issues
and making your code easier to maintain.
Since Zillow has been using
Android architecture components,
users has been experiencing
a lot less bugs in the app.
We'll keep adding
new functionality to Jetpack
across the entire Android surface.
It's easy to get started.
You can update your own app
at your own speed
and all of these components
will work on older
versions of the platform.
Learn more and get started at
developer.android.com/jetpack
♪ (upbeat music) ♪